[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video da hatte ich auch
natürlich euch geht es gut
heute haben wir die mittlerweile schon
sechste oder siebte folge meines
vermögens ich teste alle sorten eines
produktes aus dem supermarkt und heute
mit einem wunsch den ich selber auf
gelesen habe und zwar juli schwenk nach
links von dias gesehen wir haben
eingekauft und das finde ich extrem
leises oder also es war wirklich wieder
sehr verrückt ich war alleine im
supermarkt wurde haben wir so eine tüte
dazu gekauft und man kann das ja
hochrechnen das hat bestimmt 20 kilo
gewogen ungefährlich aber auch noch ein
paar andere sachen dabei und ich tanze
am band kassierer wird mich so an
was hast du denn vor das ist also diese
standardfrage das wurde jetzt schon echt
auf gefragt in denen wir die kassierer
und weißt was ich sage
geburtstagskind ein gekürzter genau die
kinder gefunden und dann sagen die aber
man kann ich gehe also willst wie das
funktioniert wir haben alle
verschiedenen sorten die probiert und
bewertet
und hier muss ich sagen ich habe davon
noch nichts probiert aus rannte das habe
ich natürlich dass er eigentlich schon
jeder mal probiert und hier haben wir
multivitamin und all die schlaumeier die
jetzt schon schwimmhilfe coca cola und
brüskierte
das sind zwei sorten die ich nicht
gekauft habt einfach weil ich sie nicht
mehr tragen kostet die habe ich meine
tasche passt und lädt ich finde die
täglich also diese colak habe sondern
feiert gar nicht und kirche genauso
wenig wahrscheinlich gibt es dass wir
hier in den kommentaren aber jetzt hat
mein geschmack denn dann würde ich sagen
bin laden gar nicht sagen ich bin extrem
geheilt auf partys an babbels was
befindet wie das schmeckt das
hoffentlich mit kohlensäure
wahrscheinlich leute als erstes haben
wir kart wii so eine kirsche und
granatapfel können wir an sich mal ganz
leis so wobei granatapfel bin ich immer
so ein bisschen haben sich etwas neues
einfallen lassen für die grünen deckel
alternativ total süß rein schlaglöcher
49 und das ganz ohne kohle habe ich
jetzt wieder bei meiner oma getrunken
sie hat nichts anderes mehr da und die
war doch noch so waren weiße das war
echt gar nicht neues player als nächstes
haben wir capri-sonne mango maracuja
habe ich auch noch nie probiert das
schmeckt extrem wie sollen getränk das
haben wir früher immer auf fußball schon
getrübten in holland ich weiß nicht dass
kennen wahrscheinlich die meisten von
euch nicht ich bin euch jemand foto ein
wenig das findet dass die string kennst
du das was du so einen mann bringen oder
so noorani shooting so schmeckt das also
doch schmeckt auch extrem gut prägt auch
den 19
also bis jetzt bin ich auf jeden fall
zufrieden
bevor wir oben mit capri sun bartz
weitermachen würde ich sagen das
überspringen war und heben uns bis zum
ende auf damit auch wieder verschwinden
bleibt und wir fahren mal kurz herum was
haben wir denn hier nettes capri-sonne
multivitamin das ist aber wahrscheinlich
so dass standard ist es nicht warum
schmeckt das anders als multivitamin
wenn zehn prozent rote flut ustream da
schmeckt anders als diese diese die man
kennt ich habe das ein extra genommen
damit ich nicht noch so eine verpackung
mit städten musste also multivitamin
habe ich auch schon mal getrunken dass
ihr schmeckt allerdings nicht wie das
multivitamin dass ich von capri-sonne
kenne sondern deutlich schlechter
deswegen gleich konzern besser geht
nicht das hat eine ganz komische neben
geschmack machen mal jemand
weiterarbeiten pietsch das könnte geil
sein aber hier haben halt auch ich sind
verschluss
weil ich ja auch nicht komisch hatte
featuring passt irgendwie gar nichts
zusammen meiner meinung nach dass das
ist ein ganz komischer geschmack soria 5
und 10
mehr ist da nicht drin das heißt wir
haben jetzt noch kaffee sollten trank
monster alarm orange
was ist das denn tropical safari cruz
pure wut und diese sprudel dinger
insgesamt noch acht stück das ist auf
jeden fall viel das heißt es gibt 14
verschiedene kaffeesorten cast dass viel
mehr gibt's nicht um einen kaffee sein
ja ja aber das habe ich jetzt nicht dazu
gezählt würden das kriterium wie drinks
dann lass uns mal jetzt hier oben
weitermachen
capri sun pure wut in lollar also ist ja
sowieso wasser drin aber wieso heißen
das motto ach guck mal eine ganz neue
verpackung die habe ich so auch noch
nicht gesehen gibt es eigentlich noch
diese aktion wo man so golden besonnen
bekommen können und dann hat man
irgendwie 10.000 euro begeben hatte gab
es punkte das weckt viel zu gesund für
seine karten die sonne steht ja auch
drauf ohne zuckerzusatz und so schmeckt
das auch also ist ja eigentlich gut wenn
es nicht so ungesund ist auch nicht so
viel zucker drin ist aber es geht ja
hier in diesem format um den geschmack
und deswegen muss ich leider nur drei
von zehn geben das tut mir wirklich sehr
leid
das problem ist aber wir haben das ja
auch noch das heißt hier von erwarte ich
jetzt auch nicht so viel und der rest
wird wahrscheinlich wieder ganz gut
schmecken machen mal jemand weiter
safari fuß
das ist aber auch nur so viel gibt schon
extrem lange oder also wahrscheinlich
habe ich das irgendwie schon mal
getrunken ich kann mich allerdings
überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern
das ist wiederum sehr nice ich habe so
das gefühl die sorten die sich schon
lange üblich märkte alle gut und die
versuchen gerade auch neue sorten zu
etablieren
aber die sind alle scheiße mega in zehn
von zehn ist es nicht aber ich würde
auch hier wieder neun von zehn punkten
geben als nächstes ich versuche jetzt
mal hier an die orange dran zu kommen
und dass der turm umfeld leute wenn ich
das schaffe 8000 likes übrigens du magst
du auch karten sollen ganz gerne mal du
hast jetzt kaffee sondern für die
nächsten dreieinhalb jahre als kind war
es immer etwas besonderes so eine karte
besonders zu trinken oder so und bei uns
hier in der berner ist absolut normal da
gibt es zum frühstück eine karte mit
capri sun orange ist ja so dass standard
dinge damit sind die auch losgeworden
glaube ich ja man und das ist halt so
die sage ich mag die nicht damit
verbinde deswegen muss ich hier auch
eigentlich sei zudem von 10 geben also
weil das habe ich früher so ab getrunken
und es ist immer noch geil capitano rang
15 von 10
die frage ist wie machen wir weiter
leute das ist schon auf als ich sie eben
ein herausgenommen hat vom design her
finde ich das so eigentlich ganz gut ist
so ein bisschen auffälliger als der rest
das ist ein lieblingsdrink davon
schmeckt aber brutal künstlich oder in
folge als ist auf jeden fall besser als
das und das und das aber hier an die
neue kommt nicht ran
deswegen würde ich mal sagen weil es
weil du das so gerne trinkt und ich das
ja auch ein bisschen berücksichtige gibt
es acht von zehn okay bis damit
zufrieden
hättest du nur zehn von zehn gegeben
tiger du musst du es ja nicht ganz gern
schlecht studierten durch nehmen das ja
okay dann haben wir jetzt noch für
foodwatch so juri markt nicht ins video
der probiert jetzt selber mal weil das
ist diese variante so ohne zucker 0 15
das recht so ein so ab wie saft der so
richtig warm geworden ist und dann kühlt
man entweder und dann tricks von uwe
daßler rücken
was soll ich da schlecht ist wie hier so
monster all das ist jetzt die letzte
sorte und dann kommen wir zu diesen
babbel dingern nach maß schmecken
monster alarm überhaupt du wenn ich das
wüsste
apfel erdbeer glaube kirche also sind
die früchte darauf abgebildet sind ist
auch ganz neues so würde ich so ähnlich
einschätzen wie dieser elfering kriegt
von mir auch acht von zehn punkte also
wenn man das jetzt mal mit anderen
sachen vergleich zu wir hatten zum
beispiel hatten wir das müllermilch die
haben schon im gesamtpaket besser
abgeschnitten
also da habe ich sehr sehr auf die zehen
verteilt oder auch die neuen kommen wir
als nächstes zu caprice an babbels also
das ist ja wahrscheinlich einfach nur
die typische capri-sonne orange mit
kunden und das könnte glaube ich kalt
richtig geschnitten
weil ich überhaupt nicht echt überhaupt
gar nicht also ist halt wie orangensaft
mit pudel wasser verdünnt und dann ein
bisschen erhitzt also so schmeckt es den
film von 10
tut mir leid und zu guter letzt traf
andre lenz ich glaube ich muss man jetzt
mal richtig lange pisten welches gab es
zank babbels himbeere
also hatten wir noch nie irgendwo
deswegen bin ich jetzt mal gespannt ob
ich das überzeugt kriege ich ja mal
nicht schlecht was kraft und spaß mit
mir das jetzt gekauft hätte ich würde es
nicht austrinken ohne spaß das ist so
getränk das würde ich nicht austrinken
wollte eigentlich nicht schmeckt ganz
komisch es fängt auch so als wenn da
überhaupt keinen zucker drin
kombiniert ist sogar zucker drin aber es
trotzdem scheiße so muss man auch erst
mal schaffen leute schreibt auf jeden
fall auch mal wieder eure lieblingssorte
in die kommentare
wir haben hier auf jeden fall kräftig an
orange das original hat am besten
abgeschnitten und 10 von 10
hier habe ich noch gar keine punktzahl
verteilt abkommen das gericht auch nur
drei von zehn
dann sind wir hier auf der gleichen
stufe capri sun tropical und caprice am
sie ihre babbels las ich in den
kommentaren müssen welche produkte ich
als nächstes testen soll
und das war dann ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen daumen nach oben blog
aktivieren aber den kanal wir sehen uns
morgen 19 uhr wieder gibt's neues video